hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 18 video all-star
team up we get to see Emily Kinney as
bug-eyed bandit character from the
comics and we got a whole lot of Ray
Palmer Superman jokes speaking of which
- there's gonna be a Batman vs. Superman
teaser that's supposed to post Thursday
morning if that ends up happening I'll
do a video for it so just keep your eyes
peeled there's a little more information
on what's going on with the trailer I'll
just explain that at the end of this
video just careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet
starting with top five moments number
five Eddie is now part of team flash
that whole first ride-along part of the
episode was so much fun just so
nonchalant with the way the three of
them were solving crimes
Eddie seemed a little flabbergasted it
was hard to tell if he was a little bit
jealous I don't think so I think he was
just surprised at how quickly they were
doing things he's still pretty fresh on
the idea that Barry is the flash so I
think he's still getting used to it
iris got suspicious later just because
he'd solved so many crimes and yes I
think that she'll figure it out on her
own
I think they'll give that to her Lois
Lane figured out who Superman was and
the Man of Steel movie I think they'll
do the same thing with Iris like she'll
figure it out on her own no one will
tell her I still feel like there's gonna
be some consequences with all the line
that's going on they'll still be some
fallout and Eddie has potential to be a
season 2 villain but we'll see what
happens with the character in the next
couple of episodes at some point the
Thawne family will have to become mortal
enemies with the Allen family whether or
not that happens this season remains to
be seen when you're thinking about that
- just think about how Slade Wilson
started out is Oliver's friend in season
1 then became the season 2 villain based
on some crazy stuff so I'm expecting
Eddie to get the same type of arc on to
number 4 though
Felicity and Ray come to Central City
the way Felicity entered the episode was
just as theatrical is the way that Ray
Palmer did it you know maybe not quite
as spectacular but definitely is much
fun she was really on fire in this
episode you know usually they give her a
lot of like the awkward comedy moments
most of that actually came from Ray
Palmer
so Ray Palmer was kind of like the true
Felicity of the episode double entendre
is all over the place and yes I do think
that Barry is a little bit jealous of
them but that's just because things are
so shitty for him right now the whole
reason that they came to Central City
though is to fix the propulsion system
on the atom suit that's that's the tech
that they gave him they didn't explain
the mechanics of a too well but I do
think they
a really good job of showing how Ray
Palmer just hasn't quite mastered the
flight system like when you see how hard
it is for him to fly into the back of
the car it takes quite a bit of doing it
it's not very graceful I think my
favorite line in the episode though was
was when Ray Palmer came in and they had
the the Superman joke
it's a bird it's a plane no it's my
boyfriend the atom theme song did they
play whenever he's flying around like
whenever he was fighting the bees later
in the episode I think there were some
cues from the original Superman score
and they're on to number three
Felicity slapped some sense into Barry
it's kind of fun watching Barry freak
out a little bit he doesn't know if he
can trust Caitlin or Cisco Felicity's
slap some sense into him and explains
her early relationship with Oliver in
the way that he kept secrets from her
she told Barry to just be honest with
them did anybody else have flashbacks to
arrow season one with like that Oliver
Felicity moments whenever he asked her
to do like those those funny hacker
things I knew the whole time but I did
it anyway because I knew that Oliver was
a good person seriously some of Oliver's
excuses were pretty lame and if you guys
didn't know just some some fun behind
the scenes arrow stuff originally the
Felicity character wasn't intended to be
a main character she was just gonna come
on as a guest star but she and Stephen
Amell had so much chemistry that they
just expanded her part and she became a
main character thankfully Barry takes
her advice though that's what that last
scene was at the end of the episode
where Barry's you know pulls down his
chart and explains that Harrison wells
reverse-flash
same person the best part of that though
was Cisco explaining how he remembers
Harrison wells killing him in his dreams
that's gonna take some explaining so
I'll explain the alternate timeline in
just a second
onto number two meet the bug-eyed bandit
brie larvan in the comics bug-eyed
bandit is a male character but he's
typically shown up in Adam storylines so
that's why they used the character in
this Adam crossover they also roped in a
lot of the themes of the Queen B
characters from the comics to there
there been several different versions of
the queen bee in the new 52 universe she
mostly shows up in Superman stories she
did say that I am the queen bee of this
hive but that doesn't mean that she is
working with the organization hive in
the flare overs in the flash of the
arrow TV shows but I think that they
might do that in the future Emily can t
probably gonna be coming back next
season it just makes sense that they
would tired to hive if they're going to
use hive on the arrow show
that hasn't been confirmed yet but
people were saying that the David Ramsey
unofficially confirmed that Felicity's
father hive we're gonna be big things in
arrow season four
just because hive was involved with the
murder of his brother so like it all
just works together it just fits that
they would put Emily Kinney with that
group that's actually good question
don't you think that if hive needed an
evil version of felicity it would be
Emily Kenny's character Felicity said
that she's never had a nemesis before so
if team arrow is gonna fight hive at
some point it makes sense to give her a
villain inside that organization to go
up against I just I feel like you need
to do that if you're gonna make Felicity
a bigger character in future seasons I
totally loved Emily Kinney in the
episode hopefully she'll come back soon
but on to my number one WTF moment team
flash is now going to start going after
Harrison wells as Tina McGee said at the
end of the episode
Harrison wells became a different person
the day that his wife died now we as the
audience know exactly why that is but
based on the teaser for the next episode
it seems like team flash is gonna learn
why that is - that doesn't necessarily
mean they'll learn who air Bart Thawne
is because there wouldn't be any records
of him in the past it is possible that
Cisco could remember his name though if
he could remember the reverse-flash
killing him then he might remember what
he said - I know a lot of you were
wondering how those flashbacks worked
like how his flashbacks to the other
timeline worked I think what's gonna
happen because it's actually a pretty
big plot point is they'll explain how
he's able to remember that of the
timeline in a future episode if you
remember Harrison wells said that when
you change the past to avoid something
really bad time we'll find a way to
replace that event with something that's
equally as bad like Cisco was killed by
the reverse-flash that was avoided Cisco
almost died in this episode because of
the bee sting
did anyone else wonder if it was gonna
be like a literal mirror moment and
Barry was gonna vibrate his hands into
Cisco's chest to defibrillate him that
way I mean he just shocked him but
because the reverse-flash like literally
stuck his hand through his heart I was
wondering if Barry was gonna do like a
version of that too to bring him back to
life Barry still learning about his
powers so I'm still holding out hope
that he'll like phase you know his fist
through the reverse-flash at some point
all in all great crossover episode I
loved the karaoke joke at the end - like
oh we're not gonna do karaoke I'm
expecting them to keep doing jokes like
they said that they're not gonna do a
musical episode like that again anytime
soon
even though I think that that would be
their big swarm a moment like Avengers
have shwarma the flash has karaoke and
dive bars I know I already asked you
guys that big question about Emily
Kinney being tied to the hive
organization but because Amanda pays
character because Tina McGee offered
some help to barry allen in this episode
do you think that the original flash
characters will help barry defeat the
reverse-flash before the finale we know
about Oliver Rachele goal and firestorm
helping about teaming up against the
reverse-flash but I'm wondering is is if
they'll call back to the original series
and they'll have like the original
characters help out too and some in some
small way so what's happening is is next
week will be another crossover with
arrow you know I don't explain it too
much just because it spoilers so be sure
to subscribe to get that video it's
gonna be a lot of fun though and I know
you're all wondering about the Batman vs
Superman trailer so what's happening is
you know I explained the teaser Thursday
morning hopefully that will happen I'll
make a video for it it'll be awesome I'm
sure April 20th is supposed to be the
day that people will be able to go into
movie theaters to see the full trailer
it hasn't been confirmed so just stay
tuned for like a future video for
updates but there's also rumors that
they're going to attach the trailer to
Avengers age of Ultron so you'll be able
to go to see Avengers 2 and the Batman
vs. Superman trailer which is like the
best nerdgasm spring moment ever it's
like the best way to start the spring
big blockbuster movie season there's
also a new Star Wars Episode 7 trailer
that's going to come this week too
because of celebration Star Wars
Celebration so I'll totally do separate
videos for all that stuff you guys you
guys don't even have to ask it's gonna
be such a big awesome thing if you guys
want to follow me on twitter and
facebook for updates on all that that
big stuff there are links down at the
bottom of the description and thank you
to everyone that's been submitting
fansubs you guys are so awesome it's
been such a huge help while you guys
wait for Batman vs Superman arrow all
those all those trailers you can click
here to catch up on arrow and you can
click here for all my flash videos thank
you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tomorrow
you